Okay. It's time for hatred, mail, hatred,
mail. Of course, when a professional voiceover
artist does interpretive readings of the hate
mail that I received day in and day out, quick
reminder about hatred, mail.
Hey,
we'd probably poison our entire family of
Trump told us too. But remember, it's not
a call
Patriot written by patriots who hate David
Pacman because America and because freedom.
Okay. We have a new word coined here. I'm
going to ask your help in getting this one
into urban dictionary. If you successfully
get this word into urban dictionary, please
send me a link. Of course, there should be
a definition that references the David Pakman
show as there is for the word Patriot fever
int and maybe some others. I'm not sure. Now
that word is feed a pile. Feed a pile. Okay.
Not Pedophile. We're reversing and the word
is feed a pile. Take a listen to this.
Pacman, you are the part of the problem because
you compare Trump narrative with Nazi narrative
about Jews. But Nazis are lying about Jews,
like they are filthy, et cetera. And Trump
never said, and you dems just handle the true.
My gay friend told me long time ago to said
to me, everybody can call me with any bad
names and I don't care. But when somebody
call me federal pile just because I am gay,
then I am really pissed off. And that your
narrative is going to be the key for Trump
when in 2020,
this is just something else. Feed a pile.
Nazis, Nazis, Naz, I. E. S. Uh, we can't handle
the true, this is not auto correctly. It isn't
gentleman's that this actually seems like
a lack of spell check more than more than
anything else. I don't have an explanation
for it. I just present it to you and uh, I'm
asking for your help in getting the word feed,
a pile into urban dictionary. That is p h
e d. O. P. L. E. Remembered, the best way
to fight hatred, autism in your community,
uh, is to sign up for a membership to our
show using the coupon code hatred 40. That's
h. A. T. R. I. O. T for zero.